[Musik]
diesmal wollte er begrüße ich jetzt sehr
herzlich ist nicht nur ministerpräsident
von brandenburg sondern auch für die
koordination der deutsch polnischen
zusammenarbeit zuständig einen schönen
guten tag guten tag herr beutel was
erwarten sie sich heute von dem besuch
von frank walter steinmeier in polen ich
hoffe dass es zum neuanfang der
beziehung auch vor allen dingen auf der
nationalen ebene beiträgt dass wir
zwischen berlin und warschau wieder mehr
kontakte bekommen dass es möglichst bald
auch wieder regierungskonsultationen
gibt die ich glaube jetzt schon gefühlt
zu mindestens zwei jahren stattgefunden
haben und dass wir in dem im großen
rahmen in den deutsch polnischen
beziehungen weiter kommen nämlich
zwischen berlin und warschau
wir haben ja momentan eine situation
dass es im grenzbereich zwischen den
menschen sehr gut funktioniert da hat
sich wirklich viel ist etabliert jetzt
durch corona gebremst aber ich bin sehr
sicher dass diese gute basis die wir da
haben früchte tragen wird auch in den
kommenden monaten und jahren aber auf
der nationalen ebene gibt es doch ein
bisschen einiges nachzuholen
das ist es vielleicht sollten wir auch
in solchen phoenix gesprächen wenn man
auch zeit hat im hintergrund zu gehen
auch darauf wert legen zu sagen wie
viele dimensionen es gibt in der deutsch
polnischen zusammenarbeit und auch
freundschaft sie sagen als
ministerpräsident auch in brandenburg
grenznah zu polen natürlich es gibt so
viele bande
sie machen den job auch jetzt seit 2014
glaube ich was was sind das für viele
banden das geht quer
also es sind alle bereiche der
gesellschaft betroffen und wir haben
sehr schmerzhaft erfahren wie eng diese
bindung sind gerade im letzten jahr in
der korona pandemie in diesem jahr gegen
die abstimmung ein bisschen besser es
war trotzdem noch schmerzhaft aber das
hier wirklich gemerkt haben dass ist in
der grenzregion bei uns gewesen als ob
meine familie auseinander reißt so groß
waren die probleme die da aufgetreten
sind probleme von denen ich vorher gar
nichts geahnt hätte weil man das im
normalen leben gar nicht so mit kriegt
aber diese grenzüberschreitenden
beziehungen
nicht nur gute nachbarschaft sondern
freundschaft gewachsen ist das ist in
den grenzregionen normalität und diese
normalität leben die menschen wenn diese
normalität nicht mehr da es empfiehlt
sie von der wirtschaft angefangen über
die bildung schulen gemeinsame kitas
beispielsweise bis hin zu sport kultur
und der ganze bereich es gibt fast
nichts was davon nicht betroffen wären
jetzt ist frank walter steinmeier auch
immer ein guter garant wenn es gilt in
heikler auslandsmissionen zu reisen
wie könnte er brücken schlagen ich
glaube es er ist genau der richtige
er kennt das amt des außenministers er
weiß dass es ein sehr schwieriges
terrain symbolen und dass er die
interessen noch in politisch äußerst
schwierig zu beurteilen sind und
gegenüber deutschland ja doch ein
bisschen janusköpfig mitunter aber ich
glaube dass frank walter steinmeier
dafür sollen kann dass es einen
neuanfang gibt und den brauchen wir
wir brauchen bessere beziehungen wir
brauchen eine bessere kommunikation
wieder zwischen warschau und berlin ist
es die frage der kommunikation oder ist
es auch die frage der werte die der
kommunikation zu grunde legen liegenden
polen in der regierung andere werte
zugrunde
ich würde er sich in politische
einschätzungen gehen ich glaube aber
dass wir gerade heute würden wir 30
jahre deutsch polnischen
nachbarschaftsvertrag feiern und wir
haben allen grund zu feiern und sie
überlegen sollten wie es nach vorne geht
wie können wir in den deutsch polnischen
beziehungen weiter kommen wie können wir
als politiker den rahmen schaffen denen
die menschen von uns erwarten um
friedlich freier frei und demokratisch
in europa zusammen leben zu können
das sind die herausforderungen für die
zukunft ich würde gar nicht so lange
nach hinten gucken aber eines noch mal
alleine die der name sagt ja was der
macht eine aussage nachbarschaftsvertrag
also wir haben ein vertrag geschlossen
über gute nachbarschaft wenn sie in ein
haus neu einziehen dann gehen sie zu
ihrem nachbarn klopfen an die tür und
sagen ja wenn es gut läuft hole ich mir
mal ein paar eier und ein bisschen mehr
bei dir
und kriegs auch und wenn es schlecht
läuft glaubst du wie mehr an die tür
weil ich die musik zu laut habe also
dass nachbarschaftsvertrag ist damals
glaube ich auch dem stand der zeit
entsprechend gewesen was wir heute
erleben in der grenzregion ist nicht nur
eine enge zusammenarbeit es ist einfach
freundschaft gewachsen und ich glaube
sogar dass wir diesen
nachbarschaftsvertrag der vor 30 jahren
geschlossen worden ist uns noch mal
anschauen können und in die zukunft
entwickeln sollten
dass wir da vielleicht auch mit polen zu
einem freundschaftsvertrag kommen wir
brandenburger haben die guten
beziehungen zu polen in unserer
verfassung stehen und momentan arbeitet
der landtag daran nicht nur die guten
beziehungen reinzuschreiben sondern hier
auch noch die freundschaft zu polen zu
manifestieren
und ich glaube das wäre auch für die
bundesregierung für die deutsche seite
in guter schritt hier auf die polen
zuzugehen und nicht immer zu sagen ihr
macht dieses falls jenes falsch klar
gibt es dinge die uns stören es gibt
aber auch dinge bei den polen die sie an
uns zu kritisieren haben manchmal zu
recht manchmal zu unrecht aber das
sollte uns nicht davon abhalten die
beziehungen enger zu binden und eine
ausgestreckte hand zu ergreifen
das ist aus deutscher sicht und aus
polnischer sicht gefragt sie können sich
ja auch gut in die polnische situation
hineindenken wo braucht deutschland
polen nicht nur als nachbarn sondern
auch als freund also erst mal ich bin
jemand der in der ddr groß geworden ist
und ohne den mut der polen wäre die
mauer 89 nicht gefallen davon bin ich
fest überzeugt der mut ja polen hat
wiederum uns in ostdeutschland damals
mut gemacht und die menschen sind auf
die straße gegangen nachdem sie erlebt
haben was in polen möglich war
mit solider schon vielen anderen und da
dieser dieser freiheitsdrang und auch
die demokratie liebe in polen die ist
überragend und ich glaube auch deshalb
muss man sich um dieses land keine
sorgen machen was die demokratische
verfasstheit betrifft ich glaube wenn
man historisch ein bisschen gewandert
ist weiß man dass die freiheitsliebe der
polen schon legendär war vor 150 200
jahren
und dass sie dem zahn getrotzt haben
genau wie vielen anderen despoten die
sie unter jochen wollten
und deswegen auf dieser basis auch die
dankbarkeit zu haben und auch zusagen
für das was polen uns an vertrauen
entgegen bringen müssen wir deutsche
immer noch dankbar sein weil die zeit
des wurden weltkriegs und die zeit von
56 millionen toten polen ist eben nicht
vergessen und sie darf nicht vergessen
sein
und dass wir heute mit polen
freundschaftlich zusammen leben können
in einer grenzregion gemeinsam arbeiten
im einem demokratischen und freien
europa das ist es ist schon ein kleines
wunder und ich denke wir sollten uns
nicht auf wunder verlassen wir sollten
an diesen wunder noch weiter kräftig
arbeiten und da gibt es viel zu tun aber
ich wäre sehr froh wenn frank walter
steinmeier heute mit seinem besuch in
polen zu einem neuanfang beiträgt ich
wäre sehr froh wenn wir demnächst wieder
regierungskonsultationen hätten wobei
ich auch die kleine anmerkung hatte ich
wäre noch fröhlicher wenn die
regierungskonsultationen dann zu dem
werden was wir beispielsweise mit
frankreich haben ministertreffen
und das wäre mein wunsch also wir haben
hier immer noch eine gewisse
ungleichheit auch in der wahl name der
außen beziehung zu polen im vergleich
beispielsweise zu frankreich für uns ist
polen ein sehr sehr wichtiger partner
und wir haben sehr gute erfahrungen in
der zusammenarbeit gemacht meint dietmar
woidke ich sage vielen dank für dieses
gespräch und ihnen einen schönen tag
ich danke ihnen alles gute
danke